I have to say I forget this every time
and we've known each other long time ago
when you come through that curtain no
one's got a smile like this guy no that
is a 900 watt smile yeah are you are you
smiling like that all the time I mean
when you're asleep are you smiling like
that yeah you wake up with a cramp yeah
best part about it's the last thing is
victim see I guess and your thing too I
have to say that you've never lost
you've never lost your accent the whole
time I've known you we've known each
other how long now you've got that
southern accent yeah I do and you say
you say yes sir to me all the time you
say I hear you say no ma'am - people
often men it's no I don't understand
have you ever has it ever started to go
away or does it ever get stronger if we
go back down south does it get stronger
it does get stronger when you go back
down south and if you get angry or tired
or drunk or if you've been on the phone
with your parents yeah so when you get
mad you actually yell in in a real thick
southern drawl oh yeah
cuz that happens a lot stuff you get mad
about someone what are you mad about
like that's my rooster you know that
kind of thing
sorry
we're friends tell them we're friends in
real life I will not do we're chums I
think I talk to you every day
on the telephone in mind I'm sorry I
preached anyway nice to see you here
yeah sure yeah you do anything on Easter
is Easter a big day for you dad I went
over to an old college friends house for
brunch and I thought I'd you know dress
up a little bit I don't always you know
get to two gussied up so we're a little
suit had a little boat I was having a
great time until I somebody pointed out
I was sitting there on a stool and I
look like I've been trilha quiz dummy
yeah you look like a ventriloquist's
dummy I did my friend Ashley came over
and she helped complete the image and I
brought it yeah
all Jacqui chatters yeah okay what's
that soft drink you really like Mountain
Dew whenever you show up this guy makes
demands you always say what is it
specifically you want not just any
Mountain Dew Diet Mountain Dew yeah you
want a Diet Mountain Dew I gotta keep
this going what what's happening oh oh
that I see what you mean yeah okay
yeah you always want a Diet Mountain Dew
and if you don't get it you get pretty
fussy don't you that is not true
yeah it is how respectfully disagree
around this guy when he doesn't get his
Diet Mountain Dew and not too happy and
he throw in at any point you've known
this guy forever
you're right and is awful I don't hear a
word he says anymore yeah I just think
it was in one ear and out the other
what happened here
we've been on TV a long time today
[Laughter]
yes this is a nine-hour show didn't me
tell you you're doing a song later on I
shall not yes no more well the wind
calms him down the pain panoramic
pictorially out I had that coming
alright we're gonna take a break
gradients Rhydian and it's all my fault
more with Jack McBrayer just a second
stick around
[Applause]
you